alors oui la saison politique américaine
qui s'annonce très très excitante en
2016 et qui va commencer très bientôt
avec les caucus de l'iowa et les
primaires uni en turquie vont servir à
choisir les candidats républicains et
démocrates en vue de l'élection
présidentielle qui va se tenir en
novembre 2016 et le grand phénomène
politique aux états unis en 2015 et
probablement 2016 également sa demeure
l'émergence de dancho danchev ce
milliardaire new yorkais et qui
actuellement est en tête dans les
sondages pour les républicains s'est
permis de dire des choses que très peu
de politiciens jusqu'à maintenant ont
plus se permettre de dire aux états unis
par exemple il veut construire un mur
pour éviter que trop d'immigrants
d'amérique latine et du mexique pénètre
au aux états unis il a traité les
migrants mexicains de violeurs et et de
tueurs will make the girl dance explique
dina training day by day pourquoi est-ce
que ça passe
dans le cas de monsieur rome sa demeure
encore un mystère mais ce que l'on
constate en ce moment particulièrement
du côté de l'électorat républicain c'est
que les gens en ont assez des
politiciens professionnels
il blâme le gouvernement fédéral il
blâme le gouvernement à washington pour
tous les maux aux états unis donc il ya
une frange la très forte de 35 % en ce
moment deux républicains qui appuient
monsieur thiam est ce que dans notre
chambre va réussir à passer le test des
primaires dont les premières vont se
manifester les caucus dans l'iowa le 1er
février
par la suite les primaires les primaires
au new hampshire est également en
caroline du sud et au nevada
ça reste à voir est-ce qui va pouvoir se
démarquer face des autres candidats
assez solides comme tom cruise également
marco rubio
monsieur tron va devoir passer le test
électoral
et c'est là pour savoir s'il a le
potentiel d'aller plus loin dans la
course
du côté des démocrates c'est un peu plus
tranquille madame clinton l'ex
secrétaire d'état ex première dame du
pays hillary clinton qui souhaite
devenir la première femme présidente de
l'histoire des états unis
ben une course assez féroce contre
bernie sanders
ce sénateur du vermont qui se qualifie
de socialistes et qui veut tenter de
redistribuer la richesse
or aux états unis mais mme clinton est
fortement en avance en ce moment sur
monsieur sands
tout ça va se conclure au mois de
juillet prochain lors des deux
conventions des deux parties les
républicains à cleveland et les
démocrates
philadelphie et c'est à ce moment là
qu'on verra qui gagnera pas ce que ce
sera monsieur 102 madame clinton du côté
des démocrates qu'est ce que ce sera
monsieur de chambre monsieur leroux bio
monsieur cruz du côté des républicains
c'est ce qu'on va suivre pour vous en